I will get up and walk the dog at 6:30 a.m.
I will eat some fruit as part of my breakfast.
I will shave.
I will clean the sink after I shave.
I will be at work by 8 a.m.
I will sit through 2-hour meetings.
I will say "yes" when you want me to say "yes".
I will be quiet when you don't want to hear me say "no".
I will take your call.
I will listen to your opinion of my friends.
I will listen to your friends' opinions of my friends.
I will be civil to your mother.
I will put the seat down.
I will separate the recycling.
I will carry your lip balm.
I will watch your vampire TV shows with you.
I will take my socks off before getting into bed.
I will put my underwear in the basket.
And because I do this,...
...I will drive the car I want to drive.
Charger: Man's last stand.